m
65 heures près de trois jours après la
catastrophe de bocquaine en allemagne
fédérale six survivants retrouvés sains
et saufs ce matin rien ne remplace le
contact direct les salons ou patrons et
demeure d'or d'emploi se retrouvent face
à face tu développes exemple le salon de
l'informatique mille emplois proposés en
cet après midi dans cinq dix patientes n
2 à la découverte d'un sport à part
entière le parachutisme un premier saut
en direct dans ce journal
madame monsieur bonjour 65 heures près
de trois jours après la catastrophe de
la mine de bocquaine en allemagne
fédérale
six mineurs ont été retrouvés ce matin
sain et sauf
ce sauvetage a rendu un peu d'espoir aux
familles des quinze mineurs encore
portés disparus
jusqu'à présent le dernier bilan en date
de cette catastrophe est de 36 victimes
claude crespo ses hommes cinq allemands
et un turc sont de vrai miraculé 65
heures après la catastrophe
leur santé est bonne eux mêmes n'ont
jamais perdu l'espoir pendant les deux
jours et demi d'enterrement à 100 mètres
sous terre
ils se sont soutenus mutuellement tout
en essayant de se faire entendre en
frappant des objets les uns contre les
autres c'est même ce qui a permis aux
sauveteurs de les repérer ce matin
pour le moment la seule certitude est
qu'ils ont échappé aux courants d'air
mortels d'opci de carbone pour quelle
raison l' enquête le déterminera
l'explosion mercredi à 12h30 a
immédiatement déclenché un coup de pouce
y ait une pulvérisation des poussières
de charbon et cet oxyde a aussitôt
envahi toutes les galeries celle des six
survivants étaient éloignés du centre de
l'explosion il est possible qu'un
éboulement les isoler du reste des
galeries conservant intacte la poche
d'air qui leur a permis de survivre
trente six cadavres ont déjà été
découverts sur les 57 mineurs enfouis et
depuis ce matin pour les familles des 15
disparus qui demeurent sur le carreau de
la mine
l'espoir a ressurgi retour triomphal
pour le président reagan à washington
après le sommet de moscou une grande
fête avait été organisée à cette
occasion et le président américain a
insisté sur le fait que désormais les
relations entre les deux grands étaient
placés sur une base stable qui allait
bien au-delà de sa propre retraite
politique jean marc il use encore les
petits plats dans les grands pour ronald
reagan mais cette fois ci en terre
américaine à la base aérienne d'andrews
accueil digne de ce qu'on réserve aux
héros de l'espace ronald et l'inde si
certes revenait du froid mais cette fois
ci avec une bien chaleureuse auréole de
succès 4000 invités et une bonne dose
d'enfants des écoles
tout avait été fait pour rappeler 1974
et le triomphal retour de pékin de
l'ancien président nixon et tant mieux
si derrière son président le vice
président bush futurs candidats
républicains pouvaient au passage
recueillir quelques miettes de cette
gloire toute nouvelle qui vient sur le
tard redorer le blason d'un ronald
reagan
soudain couvert d'éloges du même par
l'impitoyable new york times
à huit mois de la fin de son mandat ce
retour triomphal de moscou permettra
peut-être à ronald regan de terminer en
beauté au fait
nancy est contente de retrouver son
chien tout est bien qui finit bien dans
un monde aujourd'hui un peu moins sur
armée qui hier le secrétaire d'état
américain george shultz entame un
nouveau séjour au proche orient sont
arrivées attendues à jérusalem après une
escale au caire et en jordanie provoque
un regain de tension dans les
territoires occupés grèves
manifestations des habitants arabes
un palestinien a été tué par balles ce
matin en cisjordanie balles tirées par
une patrouille israélienne selon une
source palestinienne
monsieur tout ce qui se dit déçu de
l'attitude des protagonistes du conflit
israélo-arabe qui ont une tendance
dit-il à à éviter le dialogue en faisant
surtout ressortir leurs divergences pour
se soustraire un compromis éventuel est
toujours possible
la nouvelle calédonie début d'abord ce
de dialogue entre les indépendantistes
et les partisans du maintien du statut
actuel
jacques lafleur député rpcr
anti-indépendantistes s'est en effet
déclarée favorable à une partition en
deux régions du territoire
d'un côté les royalistes de l'autre des
indépendantistes dont le leader
d'ailleurs il faut le souligner jean
marie tjibaou a plutôt bien accueilli
cette proposition
noumea difficile en ce moment en
nouvelle calédonie de faire la part
entre les réelle volonté de dialogue et
celles dictées par un certain
opportunisme politique
dernière solution envisagée est
peut-être su gérer par la mission de
dialogue séparer la calédonie en deux le
nord et les îles pour les mélanésiens le
sud pour les loyalistes comme on dit ici
dans dix ans référendum sur
l'indépendance un projet qui n'a rien
d'officiel il faut bien dire mais qui
provoque tout de même quelques réactions
si c'est une véritable ouverture son
indépendance
on peut en discuter déclare jean-marie
tjibaou le numéro un du fln ks pour le
député rpcr jacques lafleur a mauvais
accord vaut mieux qu'une bonne guerre
civile il semble donc à les écouter car
certains compromis soit envisageable
avec tout de même un butoir de taille
l'un veut l'indépendance l'autre pas
mais aujourd'hui à nouméa ce sont les
derniers appels de jacques lafleur au
sacrifice réciproque des deux camps qui
provoque la stupeur
nous verrons demain si son électorat le
suivre cette nouvelle voie prise
audacieuse crise ouverte qu'à l'habitude
et la politique française c'est le
silence radio et télé obligatoire à 24
heures du premier tour de l'élection
législative demain dimanche
mais voilà un sujet qui pourra
intéresser la nouvelle assemblée il
s'agit de la revendication des
producteurs français de cassettes vidéo
qui demande que la tva la taxe qui
frappe leurs produits soient baissés
elle est actuellement de 30 3% comme
pour tous les produits dits de luxe
alors que la même oeuvre diffusée en
salle ou à la télévision n'est taxée el
k 7 % en europe et aux états unis
notamment les films vidéo bénéficie
d'une fiscalité beaucoup plus légère ce
qui d'ailleurs permet et il faut le dire
au passage aux producteurs de cinéma
d'en tirer une recette non négligeable
mais parmi les raisons plus ou moins
avoués qui ont justifié les refus
successifs des pouvoirs publics jusqu'à
présent le fait que les films
pornographiques représente un
pourcentage important des ventes de
cassettes delphine de la salle
les amoureux du septième art dénonce
injustice qui les frappent une heure
diffusé au cinéma ou à la télévision
c'est 7 % de tva la même oeuvre en
cassette vidéo est taxé à 33% tva de
luxe pour une industrie programme le
film est assimilée aux supports
magnétiques
les professionnels de la vidéo demande
aujourd'hui à être aligné sur toutes les
autres diffusion du film
ils diffusent des films ils veulent qu
avant le même traitement qu'aux cinéma
et à la télévision c'est à dire à une
tva à 7% et un fonds de soutien qui
participe à la création et à la
production d'oeuvres françaises à 33%
la vidéo française et pénaliser nos
partenaires européens bénéficient tous
d'une fiscalité beaucoup plus légères
aux états unis la vidéo en plein essor
représentent la moitié des recettes d'un
film
l'amortissement du film ne se fait
pratiquement pas en vidéo en france ça
tourne autour de 4 à 6 % alors qu'en
amérique on amortit les films en vidéo à
40 à 50% ce qui est ce qui est bon pour
la vidéo est bon pour la production
parce que plus il ya des recettes qui se
font en vidéo plus ses recettes remonte
aux producteurs déjà à l'achat du film
banalise et la vidéo est devenu un moyen
comme un autre de voir un film mais le
prix trop élevés des cas cette limite
l'évolution de ce qui est aujourd'hui
une industrie à part entière
quant à un client dépense de 100 francs
pour une vidéocassette vous avez 50
francs qui représente la tva à partir du
moment où cette tva baisse vous avez
meilleure circulation des produits de
vidéo sur le marché on peut même penser
d'ailleurs que pour la piraterie
si la tva baisse le pirate a moins de
places pour se positionner sur le marché
menacé par la diffusion massive de films
à la télévision handicapé par un taux de
tva trop élevé la vidéo français se
trouvent dans de bien mauvaises
conditions pour affronter la concurrence
92 c'est déjà demain l'emploi en direct
grâce à un face à face entre d'un côté
donc les demandeurs d'emploi et de
l'autre côté des employeurs c'est une
formule qui tend à se développer aux
états unis elle est déjà monnaie
courante dans tout pays elle commence à
le devenir en france
cette formule a pour mérite principal
d'éviter les intermédiaires les lenteurs
et puis aussi les erreurs d'aiguillage
ce week-end dans un grand hôtel à paris
un exemple eh bien il se tient un marché
de l'informatique
les entreprises présentes se propose
d'offrir 1000 emplois jacques violet
80 % des 200 milles informaticiens qui
travaillent en france changeront
d'employeurs dans les quatre ans qui
suivent leur embauche
la plus grande mobilité du marché de
l'emploi les informaticiens sont des
gens pressés qui veulent gagner toujours
plus ici rien à voir avec la mp ou les
petites annonces
moquette et petit salon rasé de près
curriculum vitae dans l'attaché case en
48 heures 5000 informaticiens
contacterons directement une quarantaine
d'entreprises
une formule qui satisfait tout le monde
j'ai envie de changer et j'ai envie de
connaître ce qui se fait ce qui se
comprend sur le marché dans ces salles
on rencontre beaucoup d'entreprises je
pense qu'il y en a une trentaine et donc
on a l'occasion de discuter directement
avec les responsables de l'entreprise de
laisser quelques purs et clown vite et
ce qui permet d'avoir un premier contact
avec l'entreprise d'envisager un
entretien par la suite
l'avantagé principal c'est de permettre
justement la rencontre directe sans
intermédiaire entre l'offre et la
demande c'est bien au complément des
petites annonces et des chasseurs de
tête et il est peut-être possible que ce
soit la nouvelle manière de recruter par
rapport aux petites et non ce qui
probablement rendre moins qu'avant
maintenant qu'ils avaient des forums les
salons de recrutement
la plupart des candidats refuseront
d'être filmé ils sont là incognito
ils ne veulent pas que leur patron
actuel sachent qu'ils cherchent un
nouveau job
il ne s'agit pas d'exotisme mais d'un
véritable sujet économique
il s'agit de la découverte et de la mise
en production d'un nouveau fruit par un
groupement d'agriculteurs de la région
de dax dans les landes ce nouveau fruit
porte le nom de baba qu agnès poirier
philippe etcheverry babacaud cet hybride
de papaye arrive des montagnes
d'équateur et de colombie depuis deux
ans on en cultive sous serre et en
secret dans le sud ouest de la france
ce pionnier du babacaud par ailleurs
producteur de concombres a pris de très
gros risques
mais il y croit il y a eu le kiwi voici
maintenant le ba-ba co c'est un ct ou
très particulier si ma foi aux femmes au
bac au difficile de comparer ceux d'hier
est très rafraîchissant très juteux et
également peut-être un petit goût citron
vert si vous voulez à l'arrière-goût
citron vert rentable le bacon un trompe
porter jusqu'à 40 fruits mais après tout
se complique délicat il supporte mal les
voyages le babacaud facilite la
digestion c'est ce que disent les
indiens d'amérique du sud
on peut le manger en sorbet en jus de
fruits en pâtisserie
tout simplement à la coque
peut-on transformer un monument
historique pour des utilisations
contemporaine bref en faire une
véritable salle de spectacle c'est la
question qui est posée à nîmes et bien à
nîmes il ya un projet qui consiste à
couvrir les arènes avec une toile mobile
alors au lieu des 23 mille places qui
sont habituellement celle des arènes il
n'y en aurait que 7000 mais actuellement
les arènes ne sont exploités que cinq
mois par an et cette durée
d'exploitation passerait à 11 mois il
faut rappeler que la commission des
monuments historiques avait donné un
avis défavorable mais qu'à l'époque
monsieur léotard qui était le ministre
de la culture avait été passé outre et
avait donné son feu vert la toile sera
monté en octobre le premier spectacle
est prévu en décembre jean pellieux les
romains plaçait une toile au dessus des
gradins pour se protéger du soleil
mais c'est contre la fraîcheur de
l'hiver que les nîmois aujourd'hui vont
couvrir les arènes voici la maquette le
projet 25 millions coûtera la moitié
d'une salle classique tendu par une
couronne métallique à mi-hauteur dégrade
à la toile plastique mesure 60 mètres
sur 90 ovale comme les arènes ont l'apli
et la déplie deux fois par an gonflé par
de l'air sous pression cette grosse
lentilles repose sur 30 poteau pour
chacun le projet final prévoit non pas
trois pieds comme sur cette maquette
mais un seul pour toucher encore moins
aux gradins sont posées sont pas ancrées
c'est important et pour tendre la somme
des 5000 mètres carrés de toile réalisée
par ses plats ne se risque pas de
s'envoler
ça ne risque pas de symboles et des
essais ont été réalisés un soufflerie
les arènes couvertes accueilleront 7000
personnes pour le même spectacle qu'en
été chauffe la corrida impensable sans
soleil mais certains refusent le
principe lui même c'est un monument
preures des fêtes de plein air
votre héros pendant l'été et
on ne compte pas arriver dans la
rotation des arènes la commission des
monuments historiques a refusé de donner
son accord le ministre passe outre le
ministre qui saura t-il dans quelques
mois le ministre suivant ne prendra pas
un avis totalement contraire la
couverture des arènes doit entraîner des
travaux de sauvegarde du monument romain
comme quoi protection et modernisme
peuvent aller de pair
les architectes michelin et gaipes elles
vont proposer leur projet aux vingt
villes d'europe du sud qui ont des
arènes les nîmois en tout cas seront les
premiers chez qui ce vaisseau spatial
atterrir à bientôt pour prolonger leurs
nuits de fête tout au long de l'année
le sport tennis bien sûr en attendant
henri leconte ça c'est pour demain
contre wilander cet après-midi finale
des dames à roland garros allemande de
l'ouest steffi graf favorite logique du
match qui va l'opposer à la jeune
soviétique et révélation du tournoi
17 ans natalia zvereva daniel kazan
natalia zvereva cje intime l'appel
natacha elle est née à minsk il ya 17
ans il ya quelques jours encore elle
pouvait traverser roland garros sans
être assailli par les chasseurs
d'autographes car elle n'était pas très
connu et pourtant elle est championne du
monde juniors après avoir gagné roland
garros wimbledon et l'us open l'année
dernière
cette année elle a réalisé le tour de
force d'éliminer elena secourable 7
mondial qui l'avait battu d'un examen au
troisième tour mais surtout martina
navratilova numéro 2 call a dominé en
deux sets dans la vie natalia aime la
musique classique et l'europe
le basketball masculin et le water-polo
elle a commencé à jouer à sept ans avec
ses parents qui pratique
ça n'a l'air et pour moi elle n'a connu
face à l'australienne nicole provis
devant qui elle a dû sauver une balle de
match en demi finale jusqu'à maintenant
elle n'a concédé qu'un seul set
dans moins d'une heure elle rencontrera
pour la première fois steffi graf
championne du monde et tenante du titre
qui aura 19 ans nous avons réussi
quelle que soit la gagnante ou sort avec
l'union de la jeunesse en football
strasbourg qui a battu hier soir sochaux
1 0 a remporté le titre honorifique de
champion de france de deuxième division
et ce soir en première division c'est la
dernière journée niort lens paris saint
germain et brest jouent leur maintien en
1ère ou leur descente en seconde
division
cyclisme autour du dauphiné libéré le
français charly mottet domine dans une
équipe où il ya désormais donc deux
leaders l'autre étant laurent fignon
jean paul ollivier dans la bande à guy
marc il y à fignon et motets on devrait
dire mottet et fignon temps le premier
2000 son sujet au critérium du dauphiné
libéré
il est leader de l'épreuve et balaie
tout sur son passage
en revanche l'ex vainqueur du tour
souffrent le martyre et l'on se demande
si laurent fignon numéro un ne va pas se
mettre au service de son second charly
mottet
la question se pose pas actuellement
actuellement on est tous là pour veut
pas le tour de france et c'est la cause
qui décidemment je crois que c'est pas
le moment de se poser ce genre de
questions mottez est serein mais fignon
se mettra-t-il vraiment à son service
oui et l'inversé est vrai aussi que j'ai
tout à l'heure c'est sur le vélo que ça
se décidera façon il ya aucun problème à
ce niveau là comme leur insu bien le
cerner dernière est comme moi ça se
passe tout le temps dans l'équipe
laurent fignon qui est un qui reprend
seulement la compétition après après sa
fracture à 10h bastogne liège est
entièrement au service de charly mottet
si dans le tour de france
les rôles sont inversés charly mottet
être en service de leurs genoux quand
une équipe c'est avant tout être au
service de l'équipe pour cerise est
celui qui est le mieux placé car mottet
est un vainqueur du tour en puissance
cette fois la confiance ne le quitte
plus d'ailleurs j'ai gagné le dauphiné
et je me sens encore plus fort et
j'espère que au départ du tour de france
et ce sera la même chose
à partir de 15h sur antenne 2 dans sandy
passion cet après-midi et bien une
émission entièrement consacrée au
parachutisme un sport à part entière
dans laquelle est la france obtient de
bons résultats d'ailleurs quatre
champions du monde actuellement son
france un sport encore mal connue que
vous découvrirez donc cet après midi
avec gérard holtz en direct de la ferté
gaucher avec un programme
au programme pardon toute une série de
sauts impressionnants et en avant
première nous rejoignons tout de suite
gérard gérard oui daniel louis daniel
nous sommes à 1500 mètres au dessus du
plus grand centre européen de
parachutisme c'est à dire la ferté
gaucher dans la région parisienne at-on
un hélicoptère de l'armée de l'air frais
étaient gracieusement avec tout de suite
nos amis voilà qui sautent là bas
regardez ce sont l'équipe de france de
voile contact
pourquoi parce que pendant trois heures
cet après midi dans samedi patients
entre 15h et 18h eh bien nous allons
vous expliquer que les équipes de france
sont parmi les meilleurs
c'est vrai en précision d'atterrissage
c'est vrai en vol relatif
et c'est vrai en boitant et puis il y
aura aussi un événement cet après midi
libre vous l'avez 20 heures je crois
qu'il faut le répéter et à 17h30 nous
verrons un document exclusive antenne de
gilbert montagné chanteur non voyant a
accepté de ses côtés devant les caméras
d'antenne 2 à 4000 mètres d'altitude en
tandem avec un instructeur de l'équipe
de france jérôme aguerre une minute que
j'ai flippé superbe entaillé alors vous
aurez toutes ces impressions tout à
l'heure on va retourner maintenant sur
l'équipe de france de voile contact qui
vont former pour nous une si dur alors
ils font ça cool star et pas j'espère ce
sont des figures fait en l'air en
descente sous voile
les parachutistes s'accrochent les uns
aux autres est bien l'équipe de france
composée de patrice girard dunks et
l'entraîneur national et le capitaine de
cette équipe de france devrait quant à
lui il a une caméra
avec lui il y à patrick castella qui est
le leader en bronze vincent ferrer
thierry caute christian voinot les voilà
les voilà au dessus du centre de
parachutisme avec le caméraman qui est
au dessus c'est patrice castella thérère
guano pour nous spécial antenne 2
l'attitude de l'équipe de france de
voile contact cet après midi vous saurez
tout tout tout son parachute hills où on
en fait combien ça coûte
comment on en fait et puis en plus on
vous montrera que c'est assez facile
puisque l'équipe des sports en a profité
aussi pour s'initier pour sauter je
chauffe à thierry blanchot jean-louis
calméjane
tout le monde y est passé voilà laniel
oui merci mon cher gérard holtz la
verdure on vous retrouve tout à l'heure
donc mais on ne va pas quitter vraiment
les nuages puisqu'on va s'adresser à
josé pour savoir quel temps il va faire
cet après-midi et puis demain et non
paiement est alors quelques petits
problèmes tout de même car le soleil
manque de vitamines les températures
chutent et de la grêle est à craindre
cet après midi sur le nord-est et ce
n'est pas fini
en effet les averses vont venir
surprendre le soleil sur la bretagne la
normandie l'île de france le centre et
le massif central
il y aura davantage de soleil sur le sud
ouest excepté sur les pyrénées ou de la
pluie et a craint mais des averses
orageuses sur les étals cet après midi
ce soir sur le midi et l'accord des
températures baissent la tête très à
cherbourg 17 à mulhouse 14 à limoges 22
à nîmes
enfin 25 sur la corse demain
l'amélioration viendra de l'ouest avec
un temps plus sec mais beaucoup de
nuages encore et des averses sur le
nord-est
merci jose avant de me quitter je
voudrais vous lire le lait que de donner
lecture d'un jugement qui est intervenu
antenne 2 avait au début de
janvier 1987 fait à deux pignons prêté à
madame geneviève dormann pour les
magazines par les magazines globe et
l'événement du jeudi
depuis lors la cour d'appel de paris a
condamné ces deux organes de presse à
verser des dommages-intérêts à madame
dorman pour avoir relaté des propos
qu'elle affirme ne pas avoir tenu
puisque en son temps nous étions faits
sur antenne 2 l'écho de cette affaire il
nous paraît juste aujourd'hui de vous
faire part des conclusions judiciaires
qui sont intervenus dont acte
voilà il ne me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter une excellente après-midi sur
notre chaîne d'abord avec les
parachutistes la rédaction sportive et
puis ensuite nous si vous louez si vous
le voulez bien pardon nous nous
retrouvons à 20h mais tout de suite
c'est l'assiette anglaise avec
aujourd'hui au menu le ba-ba qu en plus
bernard rapp